a priori un banal dîner copines ou les
mairies de la sueur ne sont pas conviés
en réalité c'est l'occasion d'une vente
prise est assez particulière ça commence
simplement par de la lingerie ambiance
bon enfant se sent à l'aise
alors on essaie avec l'aide de la
vendeuse jusque là rien de bien
compromettant
puis vient le clou de la vente les
jouets sexuels vibromasseurs et autres
godemichet ont l'effet de noël j'ai une
gamme d'objets à vendre et ont fait
jusqu'à 25% de de prix mais je vous
montrer ce qu'on fait vous avez qu'est
ce que vous en pensez d'accord et puis
vous pas votre choix
actuellement pour deux achats vous avez
un article gratuit pour les ferries noël
si vous n'en plus si vous en prenez deux
camps faisant un livre gratuit comme il
s'en ai pas besoin
j'en ai un vivant chez moi je peux a
fait aujourd'hui leur localité pour
marie c'est il connaît son catalogue à
ce qu'un jour je les ai reçus ce
catalogue est avec précieusement gardé
parce que je me disais c'était quelque
chose d'incroyable d'en savoir un
catalogue pareil et il est ravi parce
que c'est plutôt amusant sont excitants
figurez vous que pour un achat si le
dessin je vous dirais que je regarde à
30 euros l'objet en moyenne chacune aura
dépensé entre 100 et 150 euros au final
comme à chacune de ses prestations
la vendeuse n'a pas perdu son temps en
rond du soldat
de toute façon faut bien faut bien faut
bien se dire que c'est quand même pas
une taille 40 ans la victime avait chuté
comme jamais j'ai justement c'est moment
d'en profiter sans pédaler
elle et sentir regarder